foreign
hi Michelle welcome to the Ramsay show
hi I am so excited I cannot believe I'm
talking to the days around these imagine
how I feel
underwhelmed but how can we help
um so we kind of got ourselves in a
pickle that's probably all your callers
right
um
um so we
I did the day when we did the financial
piece years ago and then I am afraid to
say we kind of fell off board we had a
couple moves a baby
um and so anyway we um please don't
shave me but we bought our house
um a couple years ago and uh
bought a solar lease with well it came
with the house
um I tried to call
um recently because we're starting up
Financial Peace again because we need to
kind of you know get back in the game
and we found out I tried to see if we
could buy out the lease and
unfortunately there is no buyout option
and so I don't know what to do now as
far as like going through the process
again and do you have any documentation
on this
I do
okay
have you attempted to read it
yes is it gobbling
now they pointed it out on the line item
e that we cannot buy
out our lease and how long is the lease
we have another
15 years on it and we bought the house
two or three years ago so it was already
two years into the lead and they
transferred it over to us so you're
paying for solar panels for 15 years
unless we sell the house then either we
have
an option to transfer over the lease to
the next owners or we can pay off the
lease at that point you can pay off the
lease now if you paid all the payments
for 15 years but I don't recommend that
I asked them that they said that we
cannot oh absolutely you can they can't
stop you from doing that but they don't
have to give you a discount
that's what the line item means so that
that's that's not legal but um
what's the full amount
um I want to say I don't have the papers
in front of me but I just looked at them
last week I want to say it was about 20
000 left around there through the whole
15 years
yeah so it's over a thousand dollars a
year
okay yeah for those of you out there
considering solar panels let this be a
lesson to you either pay cash for them
or don't buy them okay
um I'm big on solar because the the
current technology on the new solar
panels is Exxon especially in a place
like Arizona
uh you can they actually work they got a
they have a break even period of about
three to five years and if you pay cash
for them it could work out you got to
really run the math and make sure in
your area it will work but in your case
you just got screwed by the by the by
the the crooks in the Solar industry uh
because this is crooked I mean this is
it's not it's not technically crooked
it's not fraud but it's immoral
uh to stick somebody in something and
with absolutely no Escape methodology so
I don't know what to tell you
um
what's the house worth
um we bought it right before the
um
um I believe when we did it it was about
I want to say five okay five hundred
thousand dollar house a twenty thousand
dollar problem what's your household
income
um about a hundred thousand a year so I
you can just put this stupid in the
budget if you want to just a line item
you pay it monthly or annually
monthly yeah just put it in the line
item stupid just put stupid in your
every dollar and just just just pay it
every month that's one thing you can do
and then just not worry about it again
just call it a day uh because here's the
thing if you give them twenty thousand
dollars now we know that 15 years from
now you're probably not in this house
so that was dumb to pay it off that way
with no discount okay because had you
invested the same amount of money
gradually over a period of time it's a
lot more than twenty thousand dollars so
I would rather you just take your money
and live about your life and just write
this down other than that if you want to
spend a few hundred dollars and go talk
to an attorney and have them write the
Solar Company a letter and say if you
don't discount this and let these people
out for a reasonable rate uh we're going
to make some kind of
problem for you I don't know threaten
them because it's just wrong it's
ethically wrong with what they've
trapped you into but it also was stupid
so you can put it in the line item as
stupid in the budget I will accept that
I'm not shaming you I'm not shaming you
because I've done stupid a lot bigger
than a thousand dollars a year I promise
you I've done a lot bigger stupid than
that so this is fairly minor in the
scope of your life it's just but what's
frustrating on your behalf I'm
aggravated because you're stuck I don't
know a way to get you out
yeah I'm upset too and I will never I
will make sure yeah why don't you call
the consumer affairs division at the
State of Arizona and ask them if they
have any suggestions
okay and uh they may have uh they may
have dealt with unscrupulous solar
companies before and uh that they may
have a loophole that has been put in
that the company wasn't willing to tell
you I don't know I really don't know of
a way but I'm just fishing around so you
know you can have an attorney try to
smack them upside the head you could
talk to the consumer affairs division
see if they know a loophole in your
state maybe they passed something like
for instance uh another rip-off that
Arizona has done a good job with is
timeshares timeshares are legalized
fraud
okay and and Arizona has got some good
legislation on the books to smack the
timeshare industry around like it needs
to be it needs to be smacked around
because they're screwing people left and
right usually old people and so they get
most often and so yeah that but
Arizona's done a good job with that so
maybe they did a good job with
unscrupulous solar but let me just
highlight one more time I am not
anti-solar right right I'm not
anti-replacing the windows in your house
but taking payments to replace the
windows in your house in order to save
that much on your electric bill because
you have a more efficient window is an
absolute scam don't do that
and solar panels is not something that
you could
resell like purchase resell or not move
to another not all ones because right
there it's like a computer think of
technology has gotten better every year
on it and so old solar panels are about
as much junk as anything you can think
of wow they're totally useless
I don't know how old these were she said
two or three years old they're maybe not
that old but the current technology on
solar is excellent if you get top of the
line stuff yeah uh I mean we've looked
at it we endorse them in several markets
but not with payments yeah stuff with it
not with a lease
yeah that's I'm so sorry I'm sorry you
got in that Michelle I wish I could help
you I wish I'm aggravated partly just
because I don't know what to do to help
you but there you go there you go so
good luck with it hun
yeah
um when you're making decisions what's
the moral of the story from Michelle's
caller when the stupid things I've done
in the past same thing when you're
making decisions slow
down
slow when it comes to wealth not making
mistakes
and doing good solid Investments and
decisions slow is fast
the best way to get rich quick is don't
get rich quick
and that's you know that's what we talk
about around here all the time and most
the mistakes I've made is when I get in
a I get my little hillbilly butt in a
hurry and I run off into a mess
and I I've done it too all of us have
done it but slow
down and then you don't step in a bear
trap like that